EXPECT TO GET THE VIDEO FROM THE
CABINET MEETING ROOM IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ANY MOMENT.
FIRST, TODAY FEDERAL AGENTS
RAIDED THE HOME AND OFFICE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PERSONAL
ATTORNEY.
MICHAEL COHEN IS THE LAWYER WHO
PAID AN ADULT FILM ACTRESS HUSH
MONEY TO KEEP SECRET HER ACCOUNT
OF AN AFFAIR WITH MR. TRUMP.
STORMY DANIELS HAS THE ALLEGED
AFFAIR HAPPENED IN 2006.
THE PAYMENT WAS MADE TO HER DAYS
BEFORE THE 2016 ELECTION.
COHEN'S ATTORNEY CONFIRMED THE
RATES AND CALL THEM
INAPPROPRIATE AND UNNECESSARY.
THE RAIDS BY FBI AGENTS WERE THE
RESULT OF A REFERRAL BY SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER TO THE
U.S. ATTORNEY IN NEW YORK.
WE HAVE FOX TEAM COVERAGE ON THE
BREAKING NEWS.
JOHN ROBERTS IS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REACTION.
WE START OFF WITH
CATHERINE HERRIDGE.
GOOD EVENING.
>> WE HAVE CONFIRMATION TODAY
FROM MICHAEL COHEN'S ATTORNEY
THAT THERE WERE RAIDS EXECUTED
ON BEHALF OF THE U.S. ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN NEW YORK CITY.
THE LAW OFFICE, AS WELL AS THE
FAMILY HOME, AND A HOTEL ROOM
WHERE THE FAMILY IS STAYING
WHILE RENOVATIONS ARE HAPPENING
AT THEIR APARTMENT.
WE RECEIVED A STATEMENT LATE
TODAY FROM HIS ATTORNEY THAT
READS IN PART "THE DECISION BY
THE U.S. ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
NEW YORK TO CONDUCT THEIR
INVESTIGATION USING SEARCH
WARRANTS IS COMPLETELY
INAPPROPRIATE AND UNNECESSARY.
IT RESULTED IN THE UNNECESSARY
SEIZURE OF PROTECTED
ATTORNEY-CLIENT COMMUNICATIONS."
TODAY WE RECEIVED A STATEMENT
FROM STORMY DANIELS' ATTORNEY,
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
IT READS AS I PREDICTED LAST
WEEK ON CNN AND MSNBC, MR. COHEN
HAS BEEN PLACED IN THE
CROSS HAIRS BY MR. TRUMP.
HE HAD BEEN SET UP TO TAKE THE
FALL.
AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MISPLACED
FAITH HAS BEEN PLACED ON HIS
SHOULDERS AND I DO NOT BELIEVE
HE HAS THE METAL TO WITHSTAND
IT.
IF I'M CORRECT, THIS COULD END
VERY BADLY FOR MR. TRUMP AS WELL
AS OTHERS."
TODAY WE SPOKE WITH A SOURCE
CLOSE TO THE PRESIDENT'S LEGAL
TEAM WHO DESCRIBED THE RATE AS
BIG DEAL, VERY AGGRESSIVE, AND
AN EFFORT BY THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MILLER'S OFFICE TO PUT
THE SQUEEZE ON THE PRESIDENT
SAYING THE LIKELIHOOD OF AN
INTERVIEW SESSION, QUESTION AND
ANSWER SESSION BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND MR. MUELLER, HE
SAID IS AT LEAST VERY REMOTE FOR
THE TIME BEING.
>> Bret: QUICKLY, SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS
POTENTIALLY ARE HAPPENING HERE.
THAT THEY FOUND SOMETHING THAT'S
LEADING THEM IN THIS RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION TO SOME MONEY TIE
OR SOMETHING THAT'S ALL IN
MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION.
BUT ALSO THAT HE FOUND SOMETHING
ELSE AND IS PASSING IT ON TO THE
U.S. ATTORNEY IN MANHATTAN.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LAW, THE
STATUTE, IF YOU DETERMINE
ADDITIONAL JURISDICTION IS
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO FULLY
INVESTIGATE AND RESOLVE MATTERS
ASSIGNED OR INVESTIGATE NEW
MATTERS THAT COME TO LIGHT, IN
THE COURSE OF YOUR
INVESTIGATION, YOU SHOULD FOLLOW
THE PROCEDURES SET FORTH.
THAT COULD BE A POSSIBILITY,
PASSING IT ON.
>> THE CENTRAL POINT, WHETHER
THIS IS GOING TO REMAIN PART OF
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION AND THERE IS SOME
TIME TO RUSSIA AND ROBERT
MUELLER HAS RECEIVED THE
AUTHORITY OR EXTENDED
AUTHORITIES FROM ROD ROSENSTEIN
TO PURSUE THIS LINE OF
INVESTIGATION OR WHETHER HE HAS
UNCOVERED EVIDENCE HE BELIEVES
IS PART OF A SEPARATE CRIMINAL
MATTER WHICH REALLY PURSUED BY
THE U.S. ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
THE OTHER BIG HEADLINE TODAY IS,
ACCORDING TO MICHAEL COHEN'S
ATTORNEY, THEY TOOK
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGED
INFORMATION.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A CLEAN TEAM GO
THROUGH THE EVIDENCE.
YOU CAN EITHER HAVE A JUDGE OR
FBI AGENTS BUT I WAS TOLD
THERE'S A HIGH LEVEL OF HIS
DISTRESS BECAUSE COHEN WAS
ALREADY COOPERATING, TO HAVE THE
FBI COME IN MIGHT BE A BRIDGE
TOO FAR FOR TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM.
>> Bret: LET'S HEAR FROM THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, WHAT THEY
ARE SAYING.
JOINING US FROM THE NORTH LAWN,
JOHN ROBERTS.
GOOD    GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOT SAYING A
WHOLE LOT ABOUT THESE
DEVELOPMENTS OTHER THAN THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN WATCHING THE
NEWS CLOSELY.
SOURCES CLOSE THE INVESTIGATION
ARE TELLING FOX NEWS A WHOLE
LOT.
THEY HAVE NO CLUE WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
THEY KNOW THE FBI SEIZED TAX
RECORDS FROM MICHAEL COHEN AT
HIS HOME, OFFICE, AND HOTEL
ROOM.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS,
IF IT'S RELATED TO SOME
REAL ESTATE TRANSACTION.
REMEMBER COHEN WAS TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER A DEAL IN MOSCOW, WHEN